Imagina que tú, un antiguo filósofo matemático,
has concluido que para que la multiplicación de
números positivos y negativos sea consistente
con todo lo que has desarrollado hasta ahora, con
todas las demás propiedades de la multiplicación
que conoces hasta ahora, necesitas que un número
negativo multiplicado por un número positivo o un
número positivo por un negativo te dé un número
negativo, y que un número negativo multiplicado
por otro número negativo te dé un número positivo.
Así lo aceptas, todo es consistente hasta ahora,
pero en realidad no tiene un sentido concreto
completo para ti, y quieres tener una intuición un
poco más profunda, más que simplemente aceptar que
es consistente con la propiedad distributiva
y todo lo demás. Entonces intentas hacer otro
ejercicio mental, dices "Bueno, ¿cómo funciona
la multiplicación básica?" Entonces, si digo 2
x 3. Una forma de conceptualizar esto es que la
multiplicación básica en realidad es una suma
repetitiva, por lo que podrías ver esto como dos
veces 3, literalmente es 3 + 3, y observa que hay
dos de estos; o podrías verlo como tres veces dos,
por lo que esto es lo mismo que 2 + 2 + 2, y hay
tres de ellos. Ambas formas de conceptualizarlo
te darán exactamente la misma respuesta:
esto va a ser igual a 6. Esto ya lo sabías desde
antes de intentar abordar los números negativos,
ahora intentemos hacer negativo uno de estos y
veamos qué sucede. Hagamos 2 x -3. Voy a poner
el negativo en un color diferente, hay 2 x -3.
Bueno, una forma de visualizar esto es usar la
misma analogía de arriba: es 3 negativo 2 veces.
Intentaré usar un código de color: 3 negativo y
luego otro 3 negativo, o podría decir 3 negativo
-3 o, y esto es interesante: si vemos aquí arriba,
en 2 x 3 sumamos 2 tres veces, pero como aquí hay
2 x -3 también podrías imaginar que vas a restar
el 2 tres veces. Entonces aquí arriba pude haber
escrito + 2 + 2 + 2 porque este es un 3 positivo,
pero ya que aquí tenemos un 3 negativo podemos
imaginar que restaremos 2 tres veces, por lo que
aquí restamos 2, por acá restamos otro 2 y luego
restamos otro 2. Observa que de nuevo lo hiciste
tres veces, entonces como este es un 3 negativo,
esencialmente estás restando 2 tres veces,
y de cualquier forma en que lo pienses obtendrás 6
negativo. Ya comenzamos a sentirnos mejor con esta
parte de aquí: negativos por positivos o positivos
por negativos te darán un negativo. Ahora veamos
a lo que no es intuitivo. Al multiplicar negativo
por negativo de repente se cancelan los negativos
y queda un positivo, ¿por qué ocurre esto?
Bueno, podemos usar este ejemplo de aquí.
Digamos que tenemos 2 negativo multiplicado
por 3 negativo. Haré primero esta forma,
vamos a multiplicar algo por 3 negativo, de
modo que restaremos repetidamente esto tres
veces sin importar qué sea. Pero ahora esto
no es un 2 positivo, lo que vamos a restar
tres veces es un 2 negativo. Permíteme aclararlo:
aquí dice que tenemos que restar algo tres veces,
entonces restamos algo tres veces, eso es lo que
nos indica esta parte de aquí, y haremos esto
exactamente tres veces, aquí arriba restamos
2 positivo tres veces. Ahora será 2 negativo,
y sabemos desde que aprendimos a restar números
negativos que restar un negativo es lo mismo que
sumar un positivo, por lo que esto va a ser lo
mismo que 2 + 2 + 2, lo que de nuevo nos da 6
positivo. Puedes aplicar la misma lógica de aquí,
pero ahora en lugar de sumar 3 negativo dos veces,
que pude haber escrito como la suma de 3 negativo
más 3 negativo, es decir, sumar -3 dos veces,
ahora vamos a restar 3 negativo dos veces. Vamos a
restar algo y vamos a restar de nuevo ese algo, y
ese algo va a ser el 3 negativo: así que negativo,
negativo, y poner nuestros 3 aquí. Y una vez más:
restar un negativo es como quitarle a alguien su
deuda, que es esencialmente darle dinero; esto es
lo mismo que sumar 3 + 3, que nuevamente da como
resultado 6. Así que ahora tú, como el antiguo
filósofo, te sientes bastante bien, no sólo todo
esto es consistente con todas las matemáticas
que conoces: la propiedad distributiva, la
propiedad asociativa, todas estas cosas que
ya sabes. Y ahora esto realmente tiene sentido
para ti, esto en realidad es consistente con la
noción original o una de las posibles nociones
de la multiplicación como una suma repetida.